how important is Free Speech in your
opinion in today's day and age oh it's
it's everything yeah it's everything I
mean if you can't say what you think and
it doesn't mean that there won't be
consequences for it you know I mean I'm
sure I could figure out a way to
seriously piss you off right now and I'm
sure and I'm sure you could figure out a
way to seriously piss me off and someone
could get punched that's just how it
works yeah but but the ability to share
your opinions share your thoughts that
is what western Society is built upon I
say it on my show all the time I'm like
man if we just if we had a DeLorean 1.21
gigawatts a little plutonium from Libya
and we could just go back to 1995. I
think we'd be golden yeah just go back
to 1995 culturally everything made sense
no one thought racism was cool nobody
hated the gays it was all fine it
doesn't mean there aren't little things
on the margins that you can always do a
little bit better but free speech is
it's the key to I mean there's a reason
it's the first amendment